الحل عندي 15
سنه عندي 15
سنه لحجات ك
حخت نفس
الوقت
كير عن
السؤالي كان دايما هما ليه بيتكلموا عن
المرات بالشكل ده ليه ماحدش بيطلع وين
صوره حقيقيه اللي
بيحصل فضل الحلم معايا و خرجت من اداد
اللغه الانجليزيه وبعد
كده ابتديت اشتغل في مجال البس كنت بشتغل
في
عربيه عمري ما فكرت ان انا ا بسول عمري
عندي الحل ان انا اعمل فيلم عن المخدرات
يحل المواقع اللي انا عشته وفرجت عل
من حوالي ممان سنين قبلت بروديوسر من
هوليوود وقلت لها ان انا عندي حلم ان انا
صغير عايز اعمل فيلم مع المخدرات فقالت لي
احكيلي عن حك حكت لها ال 600 صفحه اللي
موجودين في را
فقعد اقل من
ساعتين فاكر كويس قوي واحد اي قي انت لو
ما عملتش الفيلم ده يبقى انت اللي عشته
واللي شفته وص اصحابك مش عيه
اي ومن يومها قررت ان انا مسك
والقلم وابتدي اكتب اللي حصل
بتفاصيل الهدف ما كانش ان انا اكتب
الروايه الهدف ان انا كنت اكتب سيناريو
عشان يتحول الى عمل سلمي وناس تفرق في س
بس لماجي
اكتب التفاصيل لقيت في حوالي 1000 و وابت
اصحابي اللي حواليا يقولولي انشرها كيه
الا خدت
صفحه لغايه ب معايا 600 صفحه وقررت ساعتها
ان انا انشر الكتاب على
حسن
رادع بقى معايا ح ربع جرام وبعد كده
ابتديت اروح لدش عشان اوزع
ال اول حاجه قالتلي ان احنا شعب ما بيقرا
ودول 600 صفحه ماحدش
ق تاني حاجه قالتلي ان الكتاب بتاعك ب 50
جنيه مافيش حد بيطع فلوسك
قت مافيش حد يفع فلوس قت انا عندي مشكله
ته انا باخد فلوسي كاش وحجات س علتك ما
اعتقدش ان انت
هتعرف ومن هنا انت صدق في الحل ا قاعد اسد
حد بق 25 سنه بيشتغل في مجان الكتب وانا
قعدت سنتين بحاول اطع برساله
مهمه والفاينل ديسيجن كان جود لاك انت مشك
وابتديت اتحرك ابتديت الف مع المكتبات في
مصر كنت مش بحاول اعليهم الكتاب كنت بحاول
افهمهم انا قضيت من عمري سنتين عشان اكتب
الكتاب ده وكان ده ط انا مش عايز حد ياخد
الكتاب انا عا عايزه تخد الكتاب وقد
كان كل مرتبه كبيره في كت بدخلها كت بسيب
لهم نسخه من الكتاب واقول
لهم اسبوع وابتدى الكتاب وابتدت الكراتين
تبقى في شنطه عربيتي وابتديت اوزع كتاب
نفسي على مكتب المصري من كتر انا كنت حابب
الرساله وت ما انا كنت مختم الكتاب وت
بروح المكتبات واقف قدام الكتاب عندي ظهور
ان انا عملت الموجود ده ان انا فعلا ابتدي
اخط في
الحل فخلال 10 ايام وانا معدي صدفه على
ابص على الكتاب بتاعي وعايز اطم موجود
ازاي ومعروف ازاي مفاجا ان الكتاب بقى
نمبر فايف في
الشط
شهر كده مش اصدق نفسي انا كتابي نمبر
فايف خلال شهر الكتاب بقى نمبر تو في
الشهر الثاني كتاب بقى نمبر وان واستمر
ربع كرام لغايه النهارده الحمد لله وانا
وك سش
مصر اجمل حاجه في التاب ده ان انا ما كنتش
بخيل ان انا حس المهره ما كنتش بفكر حس
المهره كل اللي هيمني ان
الناس واجمل حاجه حصلت ان انا ات منه اكتر
ما كنت اتوقع م م ومتي او مش متهي او انا
مصدق كده انيج ل ربنا ل المجود اللي
اناه جهزنا الفيلم وابتدينا نجهز علشان
افرج على الحجم بتاعي واسكرين
ولكن الظروف كانت صعبه كان احداث يناير
قنا نقف وبعدها ج الاخوان مسك السلطه نا
بر يستنى شويه لغيه اما ارجعنا تاني
دلوقتي بقول هنبتدي تاني علشان نعمل في
المربع وانا الحقيقه مش زعل الاخر بالعكس
ليه لان في جيل جديد عمال يطلع وفي جيل
جديد عمال
يخد من ضمن الحاجات اللي انا بعملها
دلوقتي البرنامج عن المخرات في مصر وعايز
احكي لكم كده البريف ايه اللي بيحصل ما
بين قبل 25 د او خليني ارجع كمان خطوه ما
بين التمانينات العصر اللي انا كنت عايش
فيه وما بين قبل 25 يناير وما بين بعد
امبريس في
الثمانينات انا سميت الروايه رام علشان
اللي مارش
الوايه في ليله دخل ل راس السن دخل البهاق
على اصحابه كانوا بيجهزوا راس السنه
بيجهزوا الازايز الوسكي بيجهزوا حشيش
ويجهزوا عشر ويجهزوا وبعد كده دخل عليهم
بهاء قال
لهم السنه دي مش خمره ولا عشيش انا معايا
ربع جرام فرد واحد قال له ربع جرام يعني
هيعمل ايه ربع جرام فرد ب قاله يعني انت
مسهي في رو جرام دلوقتي بشوف رورا انت
هيعمل ايه
على مدار 10 سنين كاملين بنعيش بعد خمسه
اصحاب قاعدين حوالين الترابيزه ونشوف من
ربع جرام ايه اللي حصلهم الاتو السوري
اللي مكتوب ده هو اللي حصل
بتفاصيل سنه 83 لما لما بونو دخل عليهم
بربع جرام كان ربع جرام ب 600 جنيه في مصر
600 جنيه في مصر سنه 83 هحاول اجيب
اكزامبل تتخيلوا المبلغ ده ممكن يعمل
سنه 83 كان عندي عربيه لينو سك وساعتها
كانت عربيه حلوه وموديل جديد العربيه دي
جبت 6500 جنيه في 6500 جنيه سنه 83 كانوا
يجيبوا عربيه حلوه فتخيلوا 600 جنيه كان
مبلغ كبير
ازاي فالغرام كان ب 600 جنيه سنه 83 قبل
25 يناير الجرام كان ب 100 جنيه يعني السو
ب 100 جنيه فو اللي هي ممكن اعتبرها 20000
جنيه بقت تساوي 100 جنيه سنه 2010 وده ليه
لان بلدنا متغرقه بالمخدرات من
سينا احنا مش مركزين احنا مركزين جوه
البلد وسايبين الناس اللي بره تشتغل عليه
مفروط الانفاق اللي كانت معموله او لسه
موجوده لغايه دلوقتي هي اللي كانت بتدخل
لنا المقدرات لمصر واحنا مش مركزين كل
مركزين فيه الصراع اللي بيحصل ا البلد كل
المخدرات اللي بتتمسك في اسرائيل لا يتم
اعدامها المخدرات اللي بتتمسك في اسرائيل
يتم تصديرها الى
مصر ولو تتخيلوا احنا اتمسك في مصر قد ايه
في
2012 من حبوب الترامادول
345 من مليون حبايه ترمادول اتمسكت في مصر
سنه
2013 اتمسك في مصر
159 مليون حدايه
رمضان الشعب المصري بياكل عيش ب 2 مليار
جنيه في السنه الشعب المصري شرب حشيش بس ب
20 مليار جنيه في السنه فتقدر تتخيلوا
البلد عايشه في مخدرات عامله ازاي وتقدروا
تتخيلوا الجيل الجديد عايش فيه النهارده
زمان كان بيتعامل مجهود عشان نس المخدرات
دلوقتي ماحدش عمل مجهود المخدرات بتيجي
ديليفري مك التليفون مخدرات بتيجي لاي حد
مكان وهو موجود
ا انا في الفتره اللي فاتت من بعد 25 ي
النهارده عمري ماميت لا حزب ولا
اتلاف ومصدق فيله جدا مصدق في الحم بتاعي
مصدق ان انا اجي اكلم هنا مصدق ان انا الف
مدارس معاد مصر مصدق ان انا اتكلم مع
الاولاد عن المخدرات ليه لان وان وانا
صغير في المدرسه عمري ما حد يكلم معانا
عمر ما حد يه قنا هيع مخدرات طول
عمرنا واحنا صغين كنا نسمع كلمه متمن كلنا
نسال بعض يعني ايه م يعني لازم ياخد كل
يوم طب هو ليه لازم ياخد كل يوم ماحدش
بوبني على السؤال ده ودايما كنا فاهمين ان
اي حاجه ممكن تحصل لاي حد مش ممكن تحصل
لنا
احنا
الموضوع موضوع مخدرات في مصر موضوع صعب
جدا
وانا اللي انا
بعمله ان مصر ممكن تتعدل بنسبه كبيره جدا
لو الموضوع ده بس لوحده بقى ليه حلول احنا
عندنا في مصر حوالي 10 مليون
معاطي 10 مليون متعاطي مخبرات لو كل واحد
10 مليون عايش في اسره من خمسه يعني احنا
بنتكلم في 50 مليون بني ادم متاثر دايركت
المخت في
مصر هقول لكم في ج تاني تتخيلوا منه حجم
الاتجار في مصر عامل ازاي في
2013 اتمسك اتمسك 50 ال داجر مخدرات في
مصر عارفين يعني ايه 50000 لج
مسك فاكرين السد القاهره كان مليان ايام
اشس الام
الافريقيه تخيل ان الستد ده على
اخ متوقعين البلد ببقى عايشه في
ايه هرجع
للحق تاني باذن الله هنرجع تاني
نحاول ندي فرصه للناس اللي ما تقراش انها
تشوف وتفهم ان
مخدرات هحاول
الحلم
وخليني في اخر كلمتي اقول لكم حاجه سريعه
عن الحلم
باني الحلم بتاعي عمري
ماتبيع يعني ايه عمري ما تبيع يعني لما
كان نزلوا الاكرام وعمل القه كبيره قوي كل
المجين البلد
كلموني كلهم عايزين ياخدوا الحقوق يعت
اكرا ماحدش كان قادر يفهم ان انا مش ببيع
لسي ان انا عايز مت وكنت طول الوقت خايف
ان ربع جرام يتحول الى مزاج
الخير 29
حلقه من حب الناس المخدرات وفي الحلقه
30 موت كل الناس لا كت عايز كمان فرجوا
عليه ما بتمشيش كده الحقيقه بتمشيش
كده لو حد
فيست ان هو ينضم لحلم اهلا وسهلا الحلم
بدي من اول
وديد وان شاء الله ان شاء الله حفرج عليه
كلنا في نص سنه الجايه ان شاء
الله خليني
اشارككم بدايه فيلم ربع واحب اشاركها
معاكم عشان تتخيلوا احنا رايحين لفيلم ده
فين عربيه ماشيه في الطريق الصحراوي طريق
السويس
فيها ولد وبنت مش بنشوفهم بس سامعين صوتهم
بيكلموا مع
بعض الولد بيقول
للبنت
اعملنا ما تتصليش احنا بعل
بس بنسمع شويه
اصوات وبعد كده بير العربيه وهي بتقوله
اضربي بنسمع شويه اصوات بعد كده بنسمع
واحده بتقول
الله والسرنجه بتتحبس من
الشباك بنستنى شويه وبعدين بيقول لها
ولعيني
زوا بنستنى ثواني كمان والسرنجه تانيه
بتتحل من الشك بعدين بيقول لها مش قلت لك
ولعي زياره بيبتدي يتحرك بالعربيه بنلاقي
لجنه شرطه كبيره جدا اف
بيقف ولاول مره بنشوف وشه وهو بيرجع لورد
العربيه بيرجع عكس الطريق بيعدي على
الحاره اللي في النص عشان يرجع عكس الطبق
وهو في الحاره اللي في النص بنقلب عليه
جوه العربيه بيهز وبلها فوقي وهي
اوفردوز البنت بتبقى خلصانه بيقعد يحدف
على وشها ميه بيقعد يشتل فيها زع فيها هي
ما بتفش بيعدي على الطريق الناحيه الثانيه
وبيكمل بيبص في الملايه ما بلاقيش حد
بيركن ويقعد في العربيه بيفتح الباب
وبينزل وبيجر العربيه عشان ينزله على
الطريق بيقفل الباب وبيلف وبيرجع بيطلع
بالعربيه بتيجي عربيه شرطه بتقفل عليه
بينزل منها اثنين صباط واتنين امناء وثلاث
عساكر ظابط بيندي اللي علمات في القسه
اللي رماها ورا فتش العربيه هو بينت الولد
بالعربيه بيقول لهم ماعرفهاش انا لقيتها
مرميه ورا الظابط بيزق على العربيه وبيرفع
الفانله على وشه وبيكتبه بيبتدي يطلع
الحاجات اللي في جيبه امين بيخش العربيه
ويبتدي يفتش فيها بيبص تحت الكرسي بيلاقي
خمس تذاكر بدره بياخد لاث تذاكر منهم
يحطهم في جيب وبعد كده بيروح لظابط ييقول
له لقيت د
في الولد بيتاخد على البوكس وبيجي الامين
اللي كان البنت اللي مرميه ورا وبيروح
للعقيد بيقول له دي باين عليها ميته يا
باشا ربع د
[تصفيق]
اشكرك
اشرك
واتمنى باذن الله ان ناس من هنا تنضم الحم
ان شاء الله
شكرا